hello everyone and welcome to my brand
new series city review today's subject
is the city of prague which i'm going to
rate based on a number of variables
these are public transit core policy
space management climate policies
housing policy and public safety let's
get started just like most european
cities brock has a dense extensive
public transit network that goes pretty
much everywhere train lines cover most
of the suburbs providing convenient
access to the city center
most of them operate skoda double decker
city elephant multiple units but you can
also find more exotic smaller diesel
multiple units
our trip takes us to prague main station
right in the center
yeah this thing could use some cleaning
this station is impressive though not
that big or busy by european standards
serving only about 70 000 passengers per
day
going down the escalator we find
ourselves in the main underpass
look no ceiling
the new station lobby built around the
70s looks like a retro space station
for the historical lobby we have to go
up the escalator
the old station building is absolutely
beautiful
oh look there's the underpass
but now we are ready to step outside and
experience the beauty of [ __ ] this looks
like an urban freeway because
unfortunately it is
thankfully it's a sunday so traffic is
minimal
this place used to be a nice and quiet
cobblestone pomodo with trees and tram
lines but thanks to soviet megalomania
it was all given over to cars more on
this subject later
we need to get through this mess and for
that we need the underpass
i'd love to marvel at the station
building but the highway sign is in the
way
across the station what used to be a
nice green park is now a concrete
parking lot
i feel like i'm being fried alive here
so time to get going
navigating a maze of metal railings
seriously whose idea was this we find
our way to these futuristic staircases
that no one uses to take us down to the
main entrance
in here it's even hotter than in the
parking lot and it smells like urine and
feces the human variety
locals call the park in front of the
station sherwood by the way after all
the dodgy people who congregate here
in sherwood various shenanigans are
daily occurrence
that being said public safety in prague
is top notch there are no unsafe areas
aside from prague main station there is
also mozarikovo a smaller beautiful end
station next to it for commuter trains
the tram stops right in front of it
allowing for a smooth transition
though inside it's very retro
welcome
welcome to city 17.
thankfully the building will see
complete modernization in the coming
our
years
and apparently there is a doctor's
office in here i'm not going in there my
kidneys are doing just fine inside me
aside from trains the next largest
public transit system is the metro trunk
has three metro lines a b and c with d
having broken ground recently we're now
on metro b the yellow line the last line
to open in 1985
it has that vaguely futuristic design
today considered more retro running
domestically overhauled soviet metro
trains
metro a is my favorite though with its
neat station design that even games like
deus ex mankind divided chose to include
the three metro lines connect almost all
major transit hubs in the city with more
extensions and of course metro d to come
getting a ticket is easy at the stops
you'll find these ticket machines that
sell time-based tickets for the entire
prog integrated transit network
these smaller cord only machines can
also be found on board of every bus and
tram
the ticketing system is neat tickets and
passes are very cheap a monthly pass
costs 22 euros which is now about 22
tickets and passes are valid for the
entire city and much of its suburbs
depending on the type of pass you buy
all prague public transit is integrated
into one continuous system which is
massive here's a map of the train lines
and the metro and tram lines
and metro bus and trolleybus lines
but despite the dense and efficient
public transit network cars rule most of
the city
here at this pedestrian crossing when
you try to get across you have a grand
total of seven seconds to make it happen
there are simply too many goddamn cars
in this city they are everywhere
let's stop at the beautiful powder tower
a 15th century architectural landmark
behind the traffic signs with cars going
through underneath it
this sidewalk is about five centimeters
wide fanning out into a luxurious 50
centimeters while cars get around 4
meters
the prox city center just wasn't built
for cars
but this doesn't stop people from
driving in with their gigantic suvs as
there are absolutely no restrictions on
car traffic
we are now in new town because prague
also has an even older city center a
real virtually intact medieval core with
tiny narrow streets and actual medieval
buildings as both world wars avoided the
city
and it's full of cars
even the narrowest streets aren't free
from car traffic
i cannot understand how annoying this is
to walk down this beautiful medieval
streets only to encounter more metal
boxes
a beautiful medieval cathedral you say
let's squeeze a car in there
a unesco protected fully intactable rock
town square looks like a great place for
a parking lot
the only truly car-free areas or
departure course physically wouldn't fit
the pro castle district
but for that you have to climb a lot
a lot a lot a lot
and some more
but once you're up the panorama can't be
beat
there was even a ceremony of sorts up
there by the presidential guard
[Music]
who solemnly transport the brand new
liver for the czech resident's weekly
transplant
[Music]
the pro castle area is beautiful quiet
and very atmospheric
but going down we're soon back to auto
land
i have no idea why they let this stand
in the year 2022
it's the most frequented tourist area in
prague people barely fit on the
sidewalks and they give most of the
space to cars
worse cars screw up the historic
cobblestone surface
contrast these to pedestrian-only
streets that are much nicer and livelier
otherwise enjoy your 40 centimeters of
sidewalk cause you ain't getting more
frog desperately needs some sort of
restriction on private motor traffic
this cannot go on any longer
despite all this the city remains very
walkable courtesy of the old medieval
and 19th century grid
bike infrastructure is in its infancy
though throughout me filming all this i
don't recall seeing a single cyclist
granted public transit takes you
everywhere but that's no excuse
the problem once again is cars
they take up so much space that often
there is barely any left for pedestrians
let alone protected cycling pads
so we're left with bicycle gutters at
best
in terms of climate policy ie heat
resistance results are mixed
there are lots of pleasant shady areas
but all the urban freeways paved
surfaces and concrete monoliths act as
heat radiators turning surrounding areas
inhospitable for humans
the city does have a strategy to improve
the local climate but nothing will
change as long as cars rule the streets
the current mayor adam scheinhair is
pro-pedestrian though under his rule
many areas were modified in favor of
humans like this pedestrian crossing at
motranska previously there was only an
underpass which also served as a public
toilet you can imagine seeing this
measure put in place the local
conservative district mayor filed a
lawsuit to potentially get the crossing
removed
yep
lots of underpasses were built in prague
during soviet times as corners were the
priority back then thankfully the city
is now trying to get rid of them despite
the conservative party's best efforts
brock's underpasses are just as terrible
as everywhere else
this one leading to prague main station
is particularly notorious
sandwiched between an urban freeway and
a parking garage it looks and smells
like [ __ ] compared this to the original
beautiful calm pomenade with trees trams
and the hotel wilson that used to stand
in the place of the parking garage
other districts are slowly moving
towards pedestrianization though
the road on the river pollinate just got
narrowed in favor of a wider sidewalk
and the area around the powder tower is
going to be finally pedestrianized
now all that's left is to tear down the
urban freeway cutting the city in half
the one going in front of main station
it's so bad that you can find actual
abandoned buildings along it during an
ongoing housing crisis
housing prices are out of control a two
plus 160 square meter apartment further
away from the center will cost you a
quarter of a million dollars or euros
as for rent prices get ready to spend
one half to two thirds of your salary
for a tiny apartment fall right at the
edge of the city this is due to a lack
of new housing being built due to
notoriously slow bureaucracy and the
uncontrolled spread of airbnb and
similar short-term rentals the latter is
an even bigger issue let me illustrate
if you've ever been to prague you know
that the streets in the center are
absolutely full literally sometimes it's
physically impossible to fit there are
just so many people
during covet restrictions however i went
around the center and was shocked to
find it completely empty
not a single soul
anywhere
not even old town square or charles
bridge
that's because almost nobody lives in
the proc center anymore it's all
short-term rentals
i've heard stories about russian and
chinese oligarchs buying out entire
residential blocks to operate them
purely as short-term rentals and this
whole business operation is made to look
like a friendly local thing where a guy
called peter from prague lets you stay
in his apartment for a few nights the
problem is there are 10 other repeaters
from prague all working for the same
shell company owned by someone from
mainland china
this drives up rent prices for the rest
of us and prices out essential workers
like teachers nurses garbage collectors
and so on unfortunately there are no
restrictions on short-term rentals
whatsoever so this [ __ ] show is left to
freely continue
alright it's time to review the results
public transit gets a solid 9 out of 10
comprised of coverage a 10 out of 10
quality is 7 out of 10 and affordability
a 10 out of 10. car policy is a 2 out of
10 comprised of pedestrian and cyclist
priority a 3 out of 10 and restriction
policy 1 out of 10. space management
gets 5 out of 10 made up of walkability
8 out of 10 and bike infrastructure 2
out of 10. climate policy is a 5 out of
10 and housing policy is 1 out of 10
affordability 1 out of 10 and short-term
rentals 1 out of 10 and finally public
safety 9 out of 10. overall i give brock
5 out of 10 plenty of good aspects but
many of those exist in spite of city
policies not because of them it's a nice
place to visit as a tourist but once the
newness wears off the reality will be
somewhat disappointing some of the
issues are getting resolved though so
within the next decade prog might climb
all the way to a solid 7 or if
conservatives manage to take over the
city then it solid 3.
and i thank you for watching i hope you
enjoyed this first episode of city
review there will be more to come so
make sure to subscribe and i also have a
patreon if you want to support me doing
content like this and i'll be seeing you
next time